nous pensions que la bataille
était désormais derrière nous
aujourd'hui
la paix se profile
nous pensions que nos joies jamais ne
finiraient
nous pensions que notre lumière jamais
ne s'éteindrait lesieux
puis d'être orge
[Musique]
galadriel pays de fine art in le moment
tant redouté
[Musique]
le mag ne dort jamais
il patiente
dans les profondeurs la pénombre peut
tous nous engloutir sous la montagne
notre agglo mener à bien des noms
tu as entendu parler de lui tu connais
le nom de sauron
si mal qui s'élèvent en terre du milieu
ne peut maîtriser il va se répandre et
tous nous avertir
trouve la lumière est jamais l'ombre ne
trouveras
ensemble nous pouvons gagner
combattez avec moi
chacun d'entre nous se doit de décider
quel chemin il devra emprunter
il ne peut y avoir de confiance entre un
art aurait une pierre
un
bonjour l'un ou l'autre on viendra se
briser
vous à compter tant de mensonges sur la
terre du milieu